foreign
to imagine that medicine is gradually
expanding lifespan and will continue to
do so Dennis would you like to sum it up
in three minutes for us
the first thing to say is as the
Irishman would say when you ask him
where the way is to Belfast I wouldn't
start from where you are now it's a
serious point because unfortunately over
the last 20 years or so we've focused on
the dots in the print of a message
without paying attention to the message
itself those dots of the genes and the
genomics in which we've spent hundreds
of billions as a world in understanding
documenting and getting the information
on but the trouble is that those dots
don't tell us what the message is
so the first point I would make is I
wouldn't start from where we are
how do we now look at the situation
going forward though I think we have to
reorientate our way of thinking about
how to deal with the more complex
diseases and I'll illustrate that very
briefly with work on the heart if I ask
the question
where is a heart a rhythmia where is the
extraordinary circulation of electricity
called defibrillation which
unfortunately kills people suddenly and
in good health normally
where is that it's not in the genes
it's actually at the high level
even above the level of cells let alone
molecules in the way in which the
process occurs at the level of the organ
as a whole we will have therefore to
start paying attention to the different
levels of organization in biological
systems and focus where the disease is
if I want to cure an arrhythmia I'm
going to have to focus at a much higher
level than the individual molecules that
doesn't mean to say that they are not
doing something there are mutations in
genes that will predispose people to
arrhythmia for example but that's not
the level at which to understand the
arrhythmia and how you may treat it so I
think roughly speaking we wouldn't want
to start from where we are but we have
to
the Irishman was right
but
what now we do is open to a lot of very
careful thinking because thinking about
the higher levels of organization in
biology is much more difficult than
thinking about the level of molecules
and genes there's my brief statement
thank you Dennis
Nessa and what do you think is it a
mistake to imagine that medicine is
going to gradually expand and save us
all
you can see if you can read my t-shirt
I'm very my jumper I'm very clearly a
member of Team science here yeah and
science has made enormous impacts on
human lifespan
um that that's incontrovertible
sometimes it wasn't just science it was
things like soap was created before we
understood about germs and that made a
huge difference to you but science has
made an enormous difference
however
um
lots of those differences have been at
the level of childhood diseases so lots
of people died very very young which
doesn't happen anymore because of
vaccination
but if there's one thing that science's
impact on health has taught us is that
we're all going to die of something
so we all worry now about why many so
many people die from cancer it's because
they're not dying from heart attacks
things like the statins have made an
enormous difference
I don't believe you can expand human
lifespan indefinitely because I think it
makes no evolutionary sense we already
live far longer than we should in
evolutionary terms we live long beyond
our reproductive capacity so we're
already stretching things
also it's not about how long you live
it's about how well you live most people
would prefer to die
in a good state of health at 85 than to
live another 10 years in terrible
terrible health and so when we think
about longevity we need to think about
do we mean actual years or do we mean
quality of life up to a certain stage
I think though even if
then to say a healthy lifestyle to the
age of 120 130 would it be morally
responsible to do so
the massively climbing human population
has nothing to do with birth rates birth
rates have been dropping for decades
it's because people aren't dying
as early and now I have no intention as
an individual volunteering to take one
for the planetary team on that but that
is what is driving population growth and
if we do start massively extending
population age from say 85 to 120 and
it's not going to be happening in the
lower middle income countries that's
going to be because of things we do to
ourselves in the highly developed
economically developed economically
countries yeah that made no sense at all
you know what I mean
um and we're already the ones driving
destruction of the planet because our
consumption is so high so I think there
are both scientific questions and I
don't think we can live forever and
there are ethical questions and there
are also economic questions everyone
talks about we need new antibiotics we
have new antibiotics the last two
companies to develop new antibiotics
went bankrupt within six months we need
new economic models to promote greater
health for the global population which
will lead to longer term
healthy life for everybody not just for
a few individuals in the developed North
thank you thank you so we would end up
with the Haves and have-nots becoming
worse it would be the lives and lives
inequalities the most damaging people
would be alive longer to do more and
more damage and create greater problems
for the have-nots hmm
um guy
what do you think
so the title of this session is medicine
myth and I want to talk about three
um different but related medical myths
the first is that medicine is about
preventing Death Or should be about
preventing death the problem is that
medicine and public health generally has
been very successful on this and this
resulted in a large extension of
lifespan on average it's more than
doubled in the last 200 years but the
the so that's a good thing but the
problem is that we've done nothing about
the rate of aging and because aging
increases exponentially uh with the age
that you live we end up aging much more
uh before we die and that's associated
with many different age-related diseases
such as dementia and extreme aging so
you end up with a degenerative end to
life
the second myth that I want to explore
is that aging is natural
many people say that aging is natural
and therefore we shouldn't do anything
about it well the opposite is the case
aging is very rare in in the in animals
in the wild and it was very rare or
extreme aging was extremely rare for
humans before civilization up to a few
hundred years ago
um so aging is not natural it's a
product of a culture our culture and
it's a culture that has continually
targeted acute causes of death resulting
in an in large increase in lifespan
resulting in extreme aging
third myth that I wanted to explore in
relation to medicine is the Hippocratic
Oath
so we should do no harm
the issue is that with a degenerative
end to life and some people experiencing
at the end of life a negative quality of
life wanting to die because they have
degenerative diseases
um it would be rational
um to have assisted dying in the
specific conditions where you have
degenerative uh disease but that is an
issue in relation to the Hippocratic
Oath so I'd like to also discuss that
thank you thank you
um
since we're all as you said we're all
going to die of something
what is it that we're going to die of
because that we've talked about two
different things there's just the
mechanical something's going to fall off
or stop working presumably there's a
finite number of things that can just
stop working but then there's things
that are nothing to do with us outside
diseases like viruses is there an
indefinite amount of things that we
could die of or is it is is there a list
that medicine is going to get through
um we'll always see particularly the
emergence of new zoonotic diseases
coming from the Animal Kingdom and that
will only get worse because we're
breaking down the boundaries with the
Animal Kingdom so unless we have
ecosystem restoration at a global level
that's going to continue happening
however I think science will get much
much better at dealing with those
um the response to covid
is a scientific miracle if such a thing
exists you know it's extraordinarily how
fast particularly the vaccines were
developed but we will constantly see new
diseases emerging and we as Dennis said
we are extraordinarily complex organisms
if you fix one bit it just creates space
for another bit to go wrong so I think
we we might find new interesting ways to
die
um
but I don't think we'll ever stop it
I think we are finding new uh
interesting ways to die
um your question was is there a fixed
number of diseases or or is a potential
infinite number one well historically we
have targeted as a society whatever is
the main cause of death
um and we've had increased lifespan and
that reveals new diseases because aging
is not one it's dozens or maybe hundreds
of different processes and you go as you
go into extreme aging you reveal more
and more processes and more and more
diseases so in the last 20 or 30 to do
years many new diseases have been seen
because people are living to longer and
longer years
um and that's obviously a problem the
main cause of death now in the UK is
dementia that is the main cause and has
been uh well prior to the pandemic
during the pandemic uh covid was the
main cause of death but it was closely
followed by dementia and dementia is now
um again the main cause of death and
obviously that is a problem but if you
remove dementia then another thing will
be removed will be revealed by extreme
aging right to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas